20 year-old Megan halav a and her
boyfriend Johnny hit the beach at salmon
creek near the small fishing village of
bodega bay
on that day the weather is calm the
water glassy and the waves cresting at
10 feet
we just hide down the beach because we
saw three of our friends our out in the
water down there really good better than
anywhere else
they paddle out 200 yards to join a pack
of surfers but Megan decides to paddle
out another 20 feet
I was sitting a little bit north of the
pack just because there's a wave there I
liked better than the waves they were
surfing
I was alone sitting there and I started
to get just like a eerie feeling almost
like warm tingles in my spine
right as I took one stroke in the water
this shark just came out of the water
hit me
a massive great white shark sinks its
teeth into Megan's thigh one wrong move
and she'll lose her leg or worse I was
just pushing myself away from it almost
feeling like I was pushing down on it
but it was only I couldn't move that it
can do anything the shark
let's go but Megan's not out of danger
she screams for help attracting the
attention of Britt horn a lifeguard
surfing on his day off I turned saw the
shark's fin I knew it was a really big
shark just from the size of fin it
looked to be over two foot maybe three
foot tall huge triangle the shark had
rolled onto its side its Peck whole
pectoral fin came out looking like
elephant ears huge
despite their fears Britt Megan's
boyfriend Johnny and other nearby
surfers thrash through the waves to
rescue Megan as soon as I saw the sucker
shark and hit Megan and started paddling
that direction I was afraid for myself
and the other surfers I had no idea
whether it was going to hit me or any of
the other guys in the water with the
sharks submerged Megan's in shock would
it attack again
I reached my hand out and the next thing
I remember I was coming up from
underneath the water and I just grabbed
on to Johnny's back and they made a
circle around me and we all paddled in
together my whole thing was trying to
keep everybody calm
staying close to Megan back on shore
Megan discovers the severity of the
injuries to her leg I tried to put my
feet down my whole leg just gave out and
before I could fall they just like
grabbed me and pulled me up the beach at
that point my main concern was just
keeping Megan's level of consciousness
up and alert and not letting her
starting to spin down and go into shock
Bodega Bay Fire Department paramedics
raced to the scene
a helicopter transports her to the
hospital where doctors treat her
injuries the shark bit deep into her
right leg from her calf to her upper
thigh based on the bite diameter of 19
inches and the teeth in her spacing of
two and a half inches in Megan's
surfboard experts estimate this great
white is between 18 and 19 feet in
length and over 4,000 pounds 2 tons the
whole thing goes from here all the way
down all the way down to my calf and
that is the span of actually just the
first 12 teeth of the shark's mouth